hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to what could be the final
episode of the last of us this has been
an amazing game so far an absolute
emotional rollercoaster i can't explain
to you how i feel about this game
because it's just too much to say in
words but
we have to move on from the beauty of
that moment and i have a feeling that
things
may not turn out perfect later on
we don't have to do this
you know that right
what's the other option
go back to tommy's just
be done with this whole damn thing
after all we've been through
everything that i've done
i can't be for nothing
very true
all right
let's finish this then
look
i know you mean well
but there's no halfway with this
once we're done
we'll go wherever you want
okay
well i ain't leaving without you
so let's go wrap this up
that's very touching
seems like ellie is
quite grown on joel
i'm just worried that's all i am i'm
nervous
because it can't all be sunshine and
giraffes
there's got to be some bad in this city
just like every other city just like
every other place we've ever gone to
there's got to be some bad
because there always is in this world
all right let's go ellis takes me back
how so it was right after everything
went down
i ended up in a triage just like this
everywhere you look you just
saw families torn apart
whole damn world seemed to have
turned upside down in a blank
is that after you lost sarah
yes it was
i
can't imagine losing someone you love
like that
losing everything that you know
i'm sorry joel
that's okay ellie
all right where am i headed
i think i need to go through this tent
to get to the other side or maybe pick
up that ladder there finally a brick
that means some combat's about to start
good
bad i think it's bad
but whatever we do what we can
all right we're fine still got some
hatchet in us
plenty of hatchet spots
all right let's do this
what do we got infected or people
is that a dog i hear
yep
all right
i think we would be able to climb up
climb up there but apparently not all
right
so which way are we going i'm kind of
running in a circle here ah here we go
hey joel
i got something for you
yeah
what here
maria showed this to me and i uh
i stole it
really ellie
stole another thing
oh
okay it's this
is probably important to keep
well no matter how hard you try
i guess you can't escape your past true
that
thank you
oh man all these
too many feels there's too many feels
right now
do we need to go through the tunnel that
doesn't look good
but i guess it heads straight to the
hospital so here we go
this time it's gonna be different
i just know it what do you mean they're
gonna be there the
fireflies i'm sure of it
i hope so
i don't know what has happened to the
fireflies i mean why were the fireflies
back in boston bombing the soldiers they
weren't any better than the bandits
that we've encountered the entire way
down here
i don't know what's going on maybe the
soldiers were just trying to hunt down
the fireflies like seriously what is the
firefly's objective
long term
because it is
really is that you
come on ellie
keep up
sounds like
we got some zom zoms
yep i see him over there
let's see
i need to get a better look that's all
it is i'm getting this out
that's a clicker
well let's not charge right in i'm just
gonna swap this out for the bow and
arrow
all right
what have we got
hello
got it
that guy hopped out of nowhere
got it
did not see that guy okay can i get a
bow back all right that's fine
now there's just the clicker over there
well i think we should just be able to
sneak pass out with no problem all right
keeping moving
this is how we do it sweet flamethrower
ammo
okay i hear more clickers over here
there's definitely more
that's a lot of them
all right just stay here for a second
ellie
i'm gonna take care of this one
maybe
maybe not it's gonna move around like a
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
got it
[ __ ] did it alert the other ones okay it
did not all right we're okay we're okay
whoo that was too close
all right oh my god
there's so many of them
kind of let's just keep at it
whoa
i hear you
got you
whoa
did i actually kill it or is it was that
just it's death whales
okay we're gonna be fine
another one down
got it okay
we're good
can i get any of these back i'm gonna
run out of them
should i say come on give me something
give me some give me some
piss i didn't get a single one back
probably because they didn't hit them in
their head
okay
what are we looking at i don't hear any
sorry i'm i'm talking very quietly
because i was very very apprehensive to
warn anyone about anything right now so
i'm just trying to be very quiet and
apparently when i'm trying to be quiet i
shut up
oh
what do i build what do i build i've got
enough of everything i would like to
have more melee here just in case
because i'm about to run out of arrows
anyway so why not pick this up
was there a door over here that i could
go through or is this just one of them
fakie doors
that's one of them fakie doors
all right come with me
ellie but be very quiet
be very
very
quiet
yeah
oh
okay full-on bricks
oh boy
this is gonna be something there's lots
of stuff over here
give me that damn brick
not
two bloaters
why
if i throw the fire will they know where
it came from
let me make another one
[ __ ] i can't
but i can make another bomb
if i throw the bomb they won't know
where that came from because it's just
gonna blow up
go get it go get it boys
get it
suck it [ __ ]
do they know where i am i think they
know
i'm pretty sure they know
they know they really know
oh god they all sound so angry
okay
all right
they sound quite upset
there's still that guy
i can just beat him in the head
scheisse
just landed right on him
let's get it right on him
there we go
you can't tell where it was he walked
into the fire again please die
yes dead okay got one of them
whoa
hello
they don't know where me i am still
maybe i can get enough stuff here that i
can make another molotov maybe
just maybe
okay can i make another molly
yes
just enough
okay sweet okay
cool beans cool beans school beans
where did he go
oh [ __ ]
get back up get back up get back up
okay
now we're gonna be very calm
collected as he walks right into this
burn to death you son of a [ __ ] burn to
death walk in it again walk in it i dare
you
he's not burning all the way
[ __ ]
[ __ ] he didn't burn all the way down
[ __ ]
but he's weak
might be able to just hang on i'm gonna
go for it we're gonna go
come on ellie come on ellie
more fire fire ammo
shorty ammo
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
and if he comes back and we do hit him
at least he's weakened that crank could
get us up there
what crate
ellie
get on up there and drop that crate for
me
that's gonna be loud
oh nelly hurry
see my back seems to be on fire what's
the deal what is going on
okay be quick about it
because we got
a bloater
right there
okay
doing okay i'm doing okay
all right so far so good
we're good
i don't think they can reach us now
all righty okay
crap really do i gotta get another
pallet
wouldn't be the one
that water looks pretty deep
hey that's what we can do once we're
done what's that
you got it
all right where are you ellie ellie
where the hell did you go you know
whatever
like i care who cares i'm just trying to
get to this hospital and that'll be the
end of this
oh that ladder up there come on ellie
ellie come on
ellie
ellie oh there you are okay finally
what the i did not want to swim there i
really didn't can i get up back up
please could i please get back up i
would really rather not be in the
water thank you okay ellie what are we
doing
gonna boost you up again
what the hell
what am i doing here am i going under
all right what have we got here
yes okay there's a pathway through this
underwater bus
unless i get trapped and drown
right here
okay now that we're above the water i'm
gonna go over and back and then get her
up on the ladder
because she can't swim
hmm
okay i think i can drop it right down
there yeah i've never really understood
the inability to swim
i mean you just kick your feet really
hard and splash around until you don't
die that's basically the gist of
swimming
as far as i know anyway
okay
it's shallow over there
shallow over where
over there and why am i up here
what the world is
i did all that to find a
it's
comic
well tough it out you've been through
worse come on
suck it up little girl
okay where'd you go all right here we
go um all right
damn bugs
and another jam door yep another jam
door
what have we got all right what's that
all right give me your foot okay
another boost
get that door open
really quite dark
there was also a hole in the fence right
here that you could have climbed through
oh well though
whatever whoa whoa
ellie ellie ellie
not that
come on come on
what the hell are you are you [ __ ]
kidding me use the goddamn
what the [ __ ] are you joking me
what the hell
what you son of a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
sorry
i was [ __ ] [ __ ] i was [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was [ __ ] that wasn't me being bad
that was [ __ ] that's what that was
fudge
like a little raw rage to get the i'm
gonna shoot him with his shotgun
didn't even get near her [ __ ] off
oh well he's just walking cool as a
cucumber nothing happened nothing
happened
okay let her die
that was my bad
why didn't i give her a weapon why
didn't she have a weapon ooh
level four i've missed the level five
toolkit somewhere probably where i
missed that workbench of mine
i know i know that there's probably
gonna be some big last encounter that i
got to be ready for so
oh well wait a minute whoa
is there okay i thought there might have
been something down there
nope nope nope nope okay
what else we got what else could i
possibly upgrade
el diablo no standard pistols uh
i don't know maybe i'll do this reload
speed would be range would be even
better i'd do both i'll do both why not
both jorge no los dos
all right we're good nicely i'm gonna
burn some [ __ ] down that's what i'm
gonna do that's what i'm gonna do right
now
nothing like a little
nothing like a little imminent danger to
get the blood flowing again
thank you
thank you someone was being used for
target practice
grody
more supplements
vitamins and minerals
good to go
got it got it got it got it got it okay
we're full up on all sorts of ammo here
right right i'm gonna swap this out for
the rifle and we'll be good to go all
right let's do this i wish i could have
that rifle of hers that had three
bullets in it that was better
ellie what'd i tell you about running
off again
there it is true that
let's get up there
so how are we gonna go about this
there's safety in
numbers that's what i thought decided
whoopsies
okay is there anything down there that i
need to go not going anywhere
how do i find i need to find another
pallet
nope didn't make it
i ain't making that joke you could have
you tried a little harder what's down
here
what have we got
okay
i don't see anything don't see anything
nice backflip oh there we go
uh oh running out of air come on come on
jewel swim faster
swim faster
a little faster
a little faster
little faster okay there we go
i hope that actually went where i needed
to go and that wasn't just a big circle
probably was just a big circle
yep
i don't know where i'm going but i'm
going there with vim and vigor
cause that's how i roll that's how joel
rolls
i think this is the right way
i think there's just pure random luck at
this point
okay all right this makes sense
and a palette
all right little lady just got another
clicker about to stab you in the back
all right your majesty
i was almost on that palette okay
where are you gonna be where are you
gonna be how about right here you come
to me
you know come
on get down
okay there
i'm on it all right one last pallet ride
oh come on
don't be so jittery you're fine
and
there you go lady
get up there
come on ellie this is probably the last
time you're gonna have to get a ladder
or whatever have you i don't even know
what you're gonna get
oh you're gonna drop that ladder okay
that makes much more sense
come on ellie
come on
come on
i'm standing
thank you
oh
damn ladder broke off the wall now
i know what i can use this for
i'll figure something out let's swim
with this sun [ __ ]
well what am i gonna do i gotta swim
with this right or i gotta get this over
there so that i can somehow get it up oh
i see what i'm gonna do i'm gonna put it
here pick it up get down
put it down again
yep here we go it makes sense i guess
that some things would be broken after a
while
i like it when game decisions are based
off of logic but this might just be a
puzzle so i might be just tooting a
naughty dog's horn
i'm tooting naughty dog's horn okay shut
up
no immaturity here
okay
i need to take the ladder down
grab it
here we go this is what i thought was
gonna happen in the first place
spend a while says i got a wooden plank
thanks i know is it gonna break again
though
and can i take it with me do i need it
somehow probably not okay here we go
hi ellie how you doing
doing good you ready to go cure humanity
oora
oh boy oh boy let me go ahead and you
follow my lead okay right behind you
oh lordy this isn't gonna be good
where did all this water come from
close one
there okay we're fine we're fine we're
fine
we're all good
got it okay come on jump
you're gonna catch me i got you
come on come on catch
didn't even need me let's get the hell
off this thing
screw that
that was an awful dramatic thing there i
thought for sure something was gonna
break why can't i run
why can't i run
why can't i run
why can't i run
that bus isn't gonna last
yep i knew it i knew it some bad go go
go go go go go go go go go
oh no
oh no
oh come on
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on
didn't know i had to press triangle on
that
oh oh i knew it i knew this i knew all
of this i knew all this was going to
happen
oh
well this doesn't seem good
where am i going where am i going what
am i doing what am i looking for
what am i doing
oh three
oh
oh hi
kelly
ow my head
oh crap oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no wait get out of there get out of
there joel get out of there gotta get
ellie come on come on
this isn't gonna end here gotta get
ellie oh my god get ellie oh my god oh
my god oh my god get ellie get ellie oh
my god get ellie get ellie
not gonna end here there's no way this
is gonna end here and now we're gonna go
we're gonna get out of here oh i'm
running out of breath i'm running out of
breath come on come on come on almost
there
there we go
nelly
don't you die on me ellie
i know you're tougher than that
cpr come on
hands in the air
she's not breathing
hands in the [ __ ] air come on
oh come on you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
welcome to the fireflies well well well
sorry about the
they didn't know who you were
nelly she's all right okay good we
brought her back
you came all this way
how'd you do it
how'd you do it
it was her
she fought like hell to get here
maybe it was meant to be
i lost most of my crew crossing the
country
yeah i pretty much lost everything
and then you show up and somehow we find
you just in time to save her
maybe it was meant to be
take me to her you don't have to worry
about her anymore we'll take care i
worry just let me see her please
you can't
she's being prepped for surgery
the hell you mean surgery the doctors
tell me the cordyceps the growth inside
her has somehow mutated
it's why she's immune
once they remove it they'll be able to
reverse engineer a vaccine
a vaccine
but it grows all over the brain
it does
oh you pieces of [ __ ]
find someone else
there is no one else listen you were
gonna show me where's
stop
i get it
but whatever it is you think you're
going through right now is nothing to
what i have been through
i knew her since she was born
i promised her mother i would look after
her then why are you letting this happen
because this isn't about me
or even her
there is no other choice here
yeah you keep telling yourself that
[ __ ]
march i'm out of here
he tries anything shoot him
delays this gift joe
get up
i said get up
go on
move
i said move
give me an excuse
you'd die first
which way
frankly i don't know what i'd do
what the [ __ ] you doing keep walking
i said keep walking
where's he operating
i ain't got time for
this where
top floor
the far end
i honestly don't know which decision i'd
make
is it really worth it
killing the girl to save humanity that's
a tough call to make
sacrifice one for the many but joel's
not the type of person that would make
that decision
he cares too much he's lost too much
there's no way he'd do that
so it's not in his person but me i don't
know what i do
it's hard for me or any of us to say
because we don't know
what we do in that situation and for
those of you with children out there
would you send your daughter in to die
to save
everyone the smuggler he's in here
the smuggler is that what i'm called
okay get ready to die [ __ ]
very violently
goodbye
come on what have you got
nothing that's what i thought
okay
come on i got a brick with your name on
it
i don't even need the brick
oh that is a nice gun you got there
buddy
i think i'll take that
i saw rifle a
not bad not bad
i won't need it though for you [ __ ]
come on
show me what you got
take you out the freaking axios all
rifle bastards
come here come here come here come here
come here
come here
get over here
i've got an axe with knives on it
you're gonna die
well now that joel's already made the
decision i can't say if i'd make the
same
i'd like to think i would but
maybe but i'm playing as joel right now
and joel is gonna kill everyone to save
ellie
unless this is what ellie wants who
knows
i think i think in the in a certain way
ellie knew that this is what was gonna
happen
and that's why she did oh grouped up
together that's a mistake
hey got a present for you happy birthday
go get it
didn't get both of you i actually threw
it past you
well that wasn't good for you was it
thank you
whoa how'd you see
me whoa not cool not cool bro
going around
sure i can
got presents for you though
[ __ ] whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay all right then all right they
got me good that was good that was good
they surrounded me on both sides i got
nowhere to go after that
well done everybody
but now
now we're gonna do this a little
differently
oh yeah buddies
friendlies
come on
come on
where are you
where are you little shits
uh
i see your flashlights
there you are
let's see
okay
a few to the left
a couple to the right just gonna let him
go by get the one behind shiv him
this is bad this bad this bad this bad
really
really
assault rifle sucks ass
don't do that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you
holy [ __ ]
damn it these guys got so much armor
there we go about that time where's my
[ __ ] shotgun
it's time to go rambo on these
[ __ ]
screw it
whoa there's one behind me
man that assault rifle there's a lot of
bullets but it's pretty weak
hello
dammit i don't have explosives
there's so many of them
[ __ ]
damn it i can't punch through their
armor
gotta move
where are you guys
where are you where are you come on come
on
oh man
these guys are testing me
where are they going
okay they still think i'm over there
good give me time to heal
sure you are
okay i think it's just a two left so i
should be okay
all right time to kill
any surprises for me huh
all right there's three left
let me get this one
okay they're both they're all down this
hallway
this guy's coming back inside
you did that yourself
come on
oh i did that
damn it where did that guy come from
[ __ ] hell
ricky in the face
that's the end of my axe just one left
i'm just gonna blow this guy's head off
or not
or he's gonna make it a little easy for
me
oh [ __ ] i didn't know there were two
punches out of your [ __ ] [ __ ]
there we go
that ought to do
that ought to do it
all right now i gotta keep moving
forward i can't take that long on these
fights
that was brutal all right see what else
i can cook up
i know i need a shiv i definitely need a
shiv
come on make the shiv
here we go
med kit
i need a melee weapon badly
all right
hopefully a lethal melee weapon would be
ideal i see some ammo over there
more of the
more of the salt rifle ammo i'm gonna
give that a try again
maybe i could just maybe i just needed
to hit him better in the face
okay let's go
any more gonna pop out on me
no you don't
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
come on come on come on down
we want some next
who's next
you are
no
really
there we go
okay need to swap out let's get the el
diablo in here let's also get my normal
pistol that i haven't used in forever
because i've got plenty of ammo for that
one
i need to swap out for this one
hunting rifle we're good to go
what's going on down there whoa whoa
damn it why does that not an instagram
that's what i want to know
god damn it you got to be joking me i
can't you can't
be you got to be [ __ ] kidding me you
gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me god damn
it why am i screwing up now
at the very end when i need to be
the best i can possibly be
just die already you stupid [ __ ]
there we go you're dead stay dead
okay come on
there we go i just gotta do controlled
bursts because these guys
their freaking armor is
way too
there we go
controlled bursts as i spray all around
their face
good enough okay top floor that's where
ellie is
gotta save her all right
shotgun it up i need to get the el
diablo out and load it
ready to roll let's do this
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are gonna pay
sorry i've been very swear heavy on this
play-through and it's very tense
see hey i'm gonna listen to this
april 28
marlene was right
the girl's infection is like nothing
i've ever seen
cause of her immunity is uncertain
as we've seen in all past cases the
antigenic titres of the patient's
cordyceps remain high in both the serum
and the cerebrospinal fluid
blood cultures taken from the patient
rapidly grow cordyceps and fungal media
in the lab however white blood cell
lines including percentages and absolute
counts are completely normal
there is no elevation of
pro-inflammatory cytokines and an mri of
the brain shows no evidence of fungal
growth in the limbic regions which would
normally accompany the program of
aggression in infected patients
we must find a way to replicate this
state under laboratory conditions
we're about to hit a milestone in human
history equal to
the discovery of penicillin
after years of wandering in circles
we're about to come home
make a difference
and bring the human race back into
control of its own destiny
all of our sacrifices and the hundreds
of men and women who've bled for this
cause
or worse
will not be in vain
ah
tough decision to make tough decision
okay who we got
is there more
is there gonna be more
where am i going actually i need to go
down that hallway over there okay okay
okay
sorry i am once again i'm being very
quiet
i'm coming ellie
okay
all right i'm close
i need to uh actually i'm gonna swap
this out for the hunting rifle again and
hopefully be able to score some freaking
head shots
no i'm not don't let him get to the kid
did that kill you or not
[ __ ] help
nope
damn it
there we go
did that kill him i don't know who knows
who can really say
did i get him i need to heal
man they got me good
i think i did get that guy nope yeah i
did not
come on
what are you doing
there we go got you
and one way back
way in the back
way in the back
ah didn't get him el diablo
damn it they're just peppering me to
death
there we go got you
oh you're not dead seriously this is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh this frontal assault thing isn't
working out i need i need more
we go got him
he's down
whoa
okay i'm coming to get you
wish i had a melee weapon i really wish
i had a melee weapon
i strangled a piss out of you
come here
come here
ain't gonna hurt
oh wait it'll hurt a lot
i remember
okay they're still over there don't know
how they almost saw me with that [ __ ]
are you sorry sack of [ __ ]
[ __ ] come on that [ __ ] got it it's
gotta kill me at some point
damn helmets always always with the
helmets
okay do i have anything to make a bomb
with
how sorry will i be
let's see if i can just hang this guy in
the face
get him out of the game any surprises
for me
maybe
oh hello
all right
it's just the two of them right should
you just detour
can i just go
yeah i can just go
cool
all right we're doing good
okay
okay
in here
let's do this jesus doctor what are you
doing in here
i won't let you take her
come on drop it this is our future think
of all the lives we'll save drop it
drop the knife
drop the knife
dude drop it
don't come any closer
i mean it
don't
do anything stupid
what do we do here maybe i'll just hit
you with this brick
wow
really
fine i'll shoot it
no
you [ __ ] animals shut the hell up
i gotta get her out of here right
come home baby girl i got you
i got you
i just shot him in the hand i don't know
what that was all about oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this isn't good
whoa
[ __ ] oh this isn't good this isn't good
come on i'm getting you out of here girl
oh my gosh
i got you
we're okay
i said get back
just barely
so
you can't save her
even if you get her out of here then
what
how long before she's torn to pieces by
a pack of clickers
that is that she hasn't been raped and
murdered first
i need for you to decide it's what she'd
want
and you know it
look
you can still
do the right thing here
she won't feel anything
uh
ah
what the hell am i wearing
just take it easy drugs are still
wearing off
what happened
we found the fireflies
turns out there's a whole lot more like
you really
people that are immune there's dozens
actually
anytime a damn bit of good neither
they've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure
i'm taking us home
i'm sorry
wait
let me go
you just come after
well
looks like we're walking
should be a straight shot through here
i'm playing ellie now wow
that was a weird kind of pretty thing
yeah
all right
now watch your head going through
here
i got it
feeling my age now i'm so confused well
i'm not confused but i don't know how to
feel right now i don't think i ever told
you but uh
sarah and i used to take hikes like this
i think uh
i think the two of you would have been
would have been good friends i think you
really would have liked
i knew she'd like i bet i would have
huh oh
look down there
it's a little bit further now
all right come on
hey wait
ah
back in boston
back when i was bitten
i wasn't alone
my best friend was there
and she got bit too
we didn't know what to do
so
she says
let's just wait it out
you know we can be all poetic and just
lose our minds together
i'm still waiting for my turn ellie her
name was riley and she was the first to
die
and then it was tess
and then sam
none of that is on you
you don't understand i struggled
for a long time with surviving
and you
no matter what
you keep finding something to fight for
now i know that's not what you want to
hear right now swear to me
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true
i swear
okay
oh wow
holy crap
that's the end
man
that was
that was an experience that was an
exploration into humanity and what a
person not a hero would do in the end
you know i think if it was ellie's
choice she might have gone for it and
been willing to sacrifice herself but
joel because joel is a flawed character
and that's what makes a great
protagonist in a story he's not a hero
in any sense but he's a great
protagonist because
he
he is inherently flawed because he can't
get over the loss of his daughter early
on the game it's established right away
he he mourns the loss of his daughter
and he literally can't get over it and
once he becomes attached to ellie
see at first in the beginning of the
game he might have been just fine with
letting fireflies do whatever with ellie
because he didn't care
then he lost tess and that's when things
started to change for him because it was
just him and ellie and he had to care
for ellie specifically so his flawed
character be fell like in love as if she
was his daughter and that was okay for
him so that when it came down to the
choice and i'm pretty sure most fathers
out there would be like they would never
sacrifice their own child for that but
that's what makes the story so
interesting that was so so emotional and
i was like they were leading up to it
like up the walk up to it they're like
after this is done i'm gonna teach you
how to play guitar and teach you how to
swim teach you how to do all this stuff
and usually when a story goes up like
that
it means that in the end
someone's going to die and it's not
going to turn out but this story is
is a story about realism and what it's
really like in the human connection
that's why there was so many interesting
things to see about how
the choices that people make in the the
ugliness of humanity that comes out in
these bad times and also the good that
comes out these bad times so you get
like a duality of that and there are
some times where the choices are where a
good person tries to make a good choice
that may not be the best for everyone
and so do the others they seem evil
like his choice to kill marlene or
whatever his name was at the end of
there that was a choice by a flawed man
not a good man
making the choice of what he thought was
best
for ellie and not best for anyone else
you know not even best
uh for the world but best for him and
best for ellie because that's the only
decision that he could have made like me
personally i might have made a different
one and everyone who plays this may have
made a difference but because
because it's so real and i love
i love stories like this like movies
like this
that base their thing on realism where
you have a hero or a hero that's in a
situation where he usually can't get out
oh look at the puppies but you know it's
fun
it's more interesting to me to see
the flawed uh hero try to find some sort
of redemption at the end and red dead
redemption is actually a good example of
this because like
things don't go perfectly you know they
don't they can go good and they go well
in certain
times and things like that but
they don't always go perfectly so
and that's the way the world is
so anyway
anyway
that is the last of us this has been an
amazing game to play i could not
recommend it more for everyone if you
haven't spoiled it for yourself already
by watching this entire playthrough i
really sincerely hope you enjoyed it i
hope you enjoyed my commentary here
thank you so much for sticking me i know
there are thousands of people that
picked my let's play over others and i
really appreciate it uh you supporting
me like this so thank you everybody so
much for watching and i can't wait to
this this game is going to stay in my
mind for a long long long time so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart
thank you so much for watching click the
annotation for more let's plays that
i've done over the years and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
you